jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub
herzlich willkommen zum Presseclub an
diesem Sonntag schön dass Sie dabei sind
am Limit riesiger Kraftakt deutschland
übernimmt sich das sind Schlagzeilen
dieser Tage zum Thema Flüchtlinge rund
eine Million Menschen aus der Ukraine
haben seit Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs hier Zuflucht gefunden
gut 100.000 Flüchtlinge sind seit Anfang
des Jahres aus anderen Ländern gekommen
in denen Krieg Verfolgung und Elend
herrschen die Zahlen erinnern erinnern
an
2015/2016 als Deutschland ähnlich viele
Schutzsuchende aufgenommen hat und als
es nach dem ersten herzlichen Willkommen
einen heftigen zeitweise hässlichen
Streit über die Flüchtlingspolitik
folgte Streit bahnt sich auch jetzt
wieder an und vor Ort wo die Flüchtlinge
untergebracht werden sollen da wächst
die Sorge dass das schon bald nicht mehr
gelingt
[Musik]
Bilder die an das Jahr 2015 erinnern
Turnhallen als Aufnahmelager in
Deutschland sind derzeit so viele
geflüchtete wie nie zuvor etwa eine
Million Menschen aus der Ukraine suchen
hier Zuflucht vor Putins Angriff und es
werden noch mehr je länger der Krieg
dauert auch aus Syrien Afghanistan und
dem Irak kommen wieder mehr
Schutzsuchende viele Kommunen sind
bereits jetzt am Limit möglicherweise
noch Zelte aufgebaut wurden und
Container wieder
angemietet oder erworben wurden dann
sind die Kapazitäten erschöpft und das
ist das was uns Sorge macht und deshalb
wir uns auch tatsächlich verstärkt auch
von Seiten der Kommunen und die
Bundespolitik wenden Angela Merkel hat
2015 mit ihrem wir schaffen das den
Slogan zur Krise geliefert ein
Versprechen das auch heute noch gelten
soll ja es wird Haken ja es wird
schwierig aber ich will es in aller
Klarheit sagen wir schaffen das über das
Wie soll nun auf dem sogenannten
flüchtlingsgipf angesprochen werden klar
ist es fehlt ein Geld und Platz noch
hält die Solidarität mit den ankommenden
ukrainer:innen doch wie lange noch wenn
sich die Wirtschaftskrise verschlimmert
über all das wollen wir heute sprechen
unser Thema Krieg fluchtvertreibung
wiederholt sich 2015 und das sind meine
Gäste auf die ich mich freue Ulrich
Ladurner ist wieder bei uns er ist
Brüssel Korrespondent der Wochenzeitung
Die Zeit herzlich willkommen ich freue
mich auf Ann-Kathrin Müller
politikredakteurin im hauptstadtbüro des
SPIEGEL schön dass Sie hier sind
herzlich willkommen an Uli Reitz
chefkorrespondent von FOCUS Online und
ein ebenso herzliches Willkommen an
manuell bewarda er ist Mitglied im
investigativ ressort des WDR
die Kommunen schlagen Alarm sie haben
einen sehr eindringlichen Brief an
Bundeskanzler Scholz geschrieben haben
mehr Geld verlangt für die Unterbringung
und die Versorgung der geflüchteten und
sie haben an
2015/2016 erinnert eine Zeit die das
Land ja in eine ziemliche Unruhe um
nicht zu sagen in ziemliche Wallungen
gebracht hat ist dieser Vergleich
tragfähig
ja also von den grundsätzlichen Zahlen
her auf jeden Fall also wir haben für
die Kommunen eine ähnliche
Herausforderung wir haben eine Zahl von
Menschen eine Million mehr als eine
Million die kommen die brauchen
natürlich ein Bett die brauchen
irgendwie jeden Tag die brauchen
Versorgung und das ist schon die
ähnliche Voraussetzung woher die Leute
kommen das ist glaube ich dann ziemlich
unterschiedlich wir haben wie sie auch
gesagt haben knapp mehr als 100.000
Asylbewerber bisher die nicht aus Europa
vor allem kommen und wir haben aber vor
allem durch den Krieg in der Ukraine
mehr als eine Million Flüchtlinge jetzt
also die Zusammensetzung ist komplett
anders aber dass die Kommunen wieder da
stehen dass sie gucken müssen wo bringen
wir die Leute unter das ist wieder
dasselbe
Frau Müller die Zahlen sind auf den
ersten Blick genauso aber gibt es nicht
doch über diese Unterschiede hinaus die
Herr Bewahrer genannt hat noch weitere
Unterschiede also dass das Land zum
Beispiel mehr Routine hat im Umgang mit
geflüchteten dass sich einfach andere
Strukturen gebildet haben und wenn wir
auch noch mal auf die Zahlen im
Einzelnen gucken
im August 2016 waren es 90.000 Menschen
die hierhergekommen sind heute sind es
16.000 auch eine hohe Zahl aber nicht
vergleichbar hoch genau also es gibt
sozusagen grundsätzlich würde ich sagen
haben die Kommunen ja damals und auch
die Länder und auch der Bund dazugelernt
also das was wir damals hatten war ja
sozusagen neu das ist es jetzt nicht
mehr sondern jeder weiß in etwa wo die
Ansprechpartnerin Ansprechpartner sind
und man muss auch sagen dadurch dass die
Ukrainer eben sozusagen erstmal
Aufenthaltsrecht haben muss man die gar
nicht erst alle noch sozusagen in
Asylverfahren bearbeiten das heißt die
Behörden an sich sind auch nicht so
belastet wie es damals war das ist ein
massiver Unterschied zu damals wo es
dann tatsächlich mal dazu gekommen ist
dass dann in Berlin irgendwie in einem
Wäschekorb irgendwie Pässe gesammelt
wurden die dann niemand mehr zuordnen
konnte also all diese Dinge gibt es
nicht mehr und deswegen würde ich auch
sagen taugt der Vergleich nicht so
richtig weil eben so viele
unterschiedliche Faktoren dabei sind
Dankeschön trotz dieser
unterschiedlichen Faktoren wir merken es
jetzt wir lesen dass wir hören dass wir
sehen es kommt schon wieder eine solche
Debatte hoch ist das Land nicht
überfordert woran liegt das Herz
es liegt erstmal simpel an den Zahlen
das ist ja gesagt worden
es kommt unten an bei den bei den
Kommunen
in Berlin ist man weit weg und die
Briefe die geschrieben worden sind die
ersten übrigens aus Bayern waren im
August nachdem dort registriert worden
ist es über die tschechische Grenze und
letztendlich auch bei Serbien neue
Einfallstore geschaffen worden sind
in den über diese Einfallstore
illegale Migration stattgefunden hat so
heißt das
und deswegen haben die Kommunen gewarnt
weil sie einfach vor dem Problem stehen
diese große Zahl von Menschen nicht mehr
bewältigen zu können das sind ja jetzt
schon Turnhallen angemietet worden Zelt
wir haben es gehört im Einspieler Zelte
wurden wurden aufgestellt und der Bund
hat bisher die Kommunen alleine gelassen
deswegen kommt es ja auch zu diesem
flüchtlingsgipfel und die Länder wir
haben den einen Spieler gesehen von
Hendrik wüst dem Ministerpräsidenten aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen übrigens war das in
seiner Regierungserklärung als er den
Satz gesagt hat Angela Merkel zitierend
wir schaffen das da muss man sich nicht
wundern wenn jetzt die Leute bei ihm
anrufen die eigenen Bürgermeister und
sagen dass ja nett dass Du gesagt dass
wir schaffen das nur sag uns mal bitte
wie das heißt wir haben tatsächlich
reale und zum Teil auch sehr große
praktische Probleme vor Ort wir haben
aber trotzdem eine andere Gemengelage
der Rahmen ist ein anderer davon ist
aber relativ wenig bei denen die Rede
sie sozusagen diesen Vergleich aufmachen
zu 2015/2016 man muss einfach sagen
diese Vergleich kommt von den Kommunen
und sie kommt und dieser Vergleich kommt
wegen der Zahlen dieser Vergleich ist
aufgenommen worden etwa von der
deutschen Polizei Gewerkschaft oder aus
den Reihen der Bundespolizei die einfach
vor Ort die größte Betroffenheit haben
weil sie die Grenzen zu schützen haben
und die sagen wir haben unser Job ist
vergleichbar mit dem von 2015 allerdings
die Gruppen die wir aufnehmen und über
die wir reden unterscheiden sich
drastisch wir haben im Prinzip eine
Privilegierung von ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen bis hinein in die
Rechtslage und wir haben wegen
verschärfterlage vor Ort Afghanistan
Irak und Syrien jetzt eine Zunahme
dieser Flüchtlinge aber die Gruppen
unterscheiden sich drastisch
uns hier in Deutschland beschäftigt das
zunehmend dieses Thema vor allen Dingen
wegen dieser praktischen Probleme wegen
der unterbringungsfrage wie sieht das in
Brüssel aus ist das da ähnlich ist es
auch da ein Thema was zunehmend für
Unruhe vielleicht sogar und Kontroversen
sorgt ja das ist ganz bestimmt so dass
das für Unruhe sorgt es ist ja auch 2015
war für die europäische Bewährungsprobe
und man hatte damals schon wieder davon
geredet dass die Union sich vielleicht
zerreißen würden Migrationsfrage aber
ich wollte solche sagen zum Vergleich zu
2015 das hat sich was verschärft nämlich
die Lage rundherum
Ukraine
ein große Ukraine wir haben wir haben in
Libanon eine Forst gesetzt also wir
haben den Zerfall Libanons wir haben
einen fortgesetzten Bürger in Libyen wir
sind sozusagen Umgehen von zerfallenden
Staaten und das war 2015 noch nicht in
diesem Ausmaß stark das heißt ich sage
das deswegen weil ich glaube aus diesen
Ländern wer sich der Migrationsdruck
verstärken das ist auch in Brüssel
bewusst und Brüssel klar seit Jahren
versucht man dorthin zu kriegen und
gemeinsam mit Asylsystem das ist ja auch
blockiert es geht nichts voran ich mache
nur ein Beispiel 220 hat
die Kommission in großen migrationspakt
vorgeschlagen sie erinnern sich 2015 hat
man die Verteilungsfrage gestellt und
gesagt wir verteilen und dann ist es in
Ordnung das ist ein Widerstand gescheit
und auch glaube ich das war so gelinde
gesagt keine gute Idee jetzt hat man von
der Verteilung Abschied genommen gesagt
es gibt keine swingere Verteilung aber
die Länder müssen sich untereinander
helfen Beispiel wenn Sie Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen nicht wollen dann müssen sie
absolut Patenschaften übernehmen das
heißt sie wollen zwar keine Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen dann müssen sie Flüchtlinge
abschieben und da müssen
länderpatenschaft die man nehmen die zu
Ländern wo sie abschieben könnte gute
Kontakte das heißt im konkreten Fall ich
bin gleich fertig und treten Fall aber
ich muss das kurz Schilder mal das so
absurd das sind konkreten Fall würde man
Herrn orbanen Ungarn 100 Flüchtlinge
übergeben damit wir sie Abschied nach
ich weiß nicht wohin das einzige gute
Beziehungen des Russland aber ich glaube
das ist dahin abschieben würde also es
zeigt nur die Verrücktheit sozusagen
gesagt versuche das zu reparieren das
ist ziemlich irreparabel glaube ich wir
kommen gleich zu der zu den Versuchen
oder zu der Verrücktheit wie Sie es
nennen zur der ihre parabilität
davor aber noch ganz kurz der Hinweis
wir streamen ja diese Diskussion hier
auch in unseren sozialen Netzwerken und
wir freuen uns über Ihre Fragen und über
ihre Anmerkungen er bewerder ich habe
gesehen dass sie eben gezuckt haben als
heladonna aus der Brüsseler Perspektive
erzählt hat was da so alles in der
Überlegung ist ja ich habe gezuckt weil
ich finde tatsächlich dass das war
eigentlich die Hoffnung der vergangenen
Jahre 2015 musste man schnell reagieren
und hat irgendwie Deals mit Libyen
gemacht mit der Türkei finde ich
nachvollziehbar wenn man nicht die
Grenze selbst besser über will aber
danach hat man ja quasi wirklich nichts
mehr auf dem Weg bekommen das gemeinsame
Asylsystem hat nicht geklappt und gerade
dieser Zentren Asylzentren an den
Außengrenzen der der EU hinzubekommen
das haben wir nicht geschafft und das
glaube ich fällt uns jetzt komplett vor
die Füße also die Ukraine wie gesagt ein
anderer Fall aber wir diskutieren immer
noch über das dasselbe wann
identifizieren wie die Leute wann prüfen
wir vielleicht mal Asylanträge und wie
funktioniert die Rückführung und das
haben wir gesagt okay 2 16 wir sind die
Zahlen gehen runter bloß weg mit dem
Problem und jetzt stehen wir wieder vor
denselben systematischen Problemen und
das ist halt wirklich ich glaube nicht
nur auf EU-Ebene das Problem sondern ja
Deutschland und Frankreich haben es in
der Ratspräsidentschaft auch nicht
geschafft das nach vorne zu bringen zu
der europäischen Ebene machen wir
nachher noch mal am Schluss ein richtig
schönen Schwerpunkt zu ich würde gerne
noch einmal zu der Situation hier im
Land kommen Frau Müller und zwar hat die
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
übermorgens einem flüchtlingsgipfel
geladen hat mit den Kommunen zusammen
und die Probleme vor allen Dingen die
Unterbringungsprobleme besprechen möchte
hat sinngemäß gesagt man es sei in der
Taten Herausforderung aber man habe die
Lage ganz gut im Griff widerspricht das
nicht vollkommen dem was aus den Städten
und Gemeinden kommt naja man muss ja
sehen dass das unterschiedliche
Perspektiven sind also natürlich schaut
die bundesinnenministerin auf dem Bund
und guckt sich eben an meldet die
Bundespolizei wirklich Probleme wie
läuft es grundsätzlich mit den Verfahren
gibt es noch genügend Beamte die diese
Verfahren machen können und
grundsätzlich ist die Lage eben nicht so
wie 2015 und man kann auch
ehrlicherweise nicht behaupten dass der
Bund die Kommunen in Stich gelassen hat
denn es gab ja im Frühjahr zwei
Milliarden Euro um die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer unterzubringen also nichts
gemacht ist einfach falsch aber
dass die Kommunen natürlich jetzt sagen
in der Lage und darüber haben wir noch
nicht gesprochen das ist natürlich ein
anderer Faktor 2015 die Energiekrise die
Preise die Inflation ja also das sind
Kostenfaktoren die dazukommen und das
jetzt die Kommunen sagen wir schaffen
das nicht bei der aktuellen Lage weil es
eben alles auch teurer wird das ist
irgendwie logisch und verständlich und
da muss der Bund auch was tun natürlich
aber das eine bundesinnenministerin
erstmal guckt ist es sozusagen
Sicherheitsproblem unterbringungsproblem
und so weiter das finde ich verständlich
Stichwort da muss der Bund was tun was
muss der Bund tun heraus
erstmal
es wird in der Koalition unterschiedlich
gesehen also die bundesinnenministerin
von der SPD sagt wir haben alles im
Griff die SPD-Fraktion die dahinter
hängt sagt wir haben alles im Griff das
ist der große Unterschied zu 2015 andere
sagen nicht wir haben alles im Griff zum
Beispiel die FDP als Koalitionspartner
die sagt wir sind was Herr Bewahrer
gesagt hat was herladonna gesagt hat wir
sind in Europa gescheitert deswegen
brauchen wir nach diesem Gipfel in
Deutschland den nächsten Gipfel auf
europäischer Ebene um endlich vorwärts
zu kommen es gibt heute in Interview vom
Bundeskanzler in der Welt am Sonntag das
übernommen worden ist von El Paris im
spanischen der spanischen Zeitung und
der Bundeskanzler antwortet äußerst
interessant auf die Frage bräuchten wir
nicht wegen Fachkräftemangel neue
Zuwanderung indem er sagt neue
Zuwanderung kann es nur geben wenn wir
die Probleme mit der illegalen
Einwanderung gelöst haben durch allerlei
Maßnahmen auf die wir ja gleich noch
kommen wollen das heißt in der Koalition
gibt es fehlende Einigkeit in dieser
Frage es wird garantiert einen
koalitionskraft geben zu diesem zu
diesem Thema und mit zwei Milliarden
kann man die Kommunen sicherlich nicht
zufriedenstellen das kriegen die nicht
hin und da herrscht im übrigen das sehen
sie ja an den Initiativen der kommunalen
Spitzenverbände der herrscht Einigkeit
über die Parteigrenzen hinweg das ist ja
kein cdu-verein der sich da beschwert
hat sondern es genauso SPD-Bürgermeister
nur ganz kurz weil das zu sagen wir
haben es im Griff glaube ich ist halt
wirklich ein Verdrängen also dass wir
eine herausfordernde Lage haben wissen
wir seit Februar März mit der Ukraine
das ist da wir wissen dass dieser Krieg
niemand hat damit gerechnet dass sie da
kriegen irgendwie von der Ukraine nach
zwei Monaten gewonnen werden wird wir
sehen steigende Zahlen im Asylbereich
seit dem Frühsommer und dann muss man
dazu sehen dass das Innenministerium
oder die Bundesregierung nicht nicht
wirklich was gemacht hat eigentlich
sollte ein Beauftragter für die
migrationsabkommen mit Herkunftsländern
kommen der ist immer noch nicht bestellt
sollte im ersten Pfad Quartal kommen wir
haben am Koalitionsvertrag wir haben ein
Staatssekretär Migrationsbereich der war
jetzt fast ein Jahr lang der Post nicht
besetzt soll jetzt kommen und dann zu
sagen wir haben alles im Griff ohne das
zuständige Posten besetzen finde ich
halt ein bisschen schwierig ich habe
nicht gesagt wir haben alles gegriffen
wir haben eine Frage oder eine Anmerkung
von Matthias Rehfeldt die ganz gut passt
der fragt auf Twitter sollten wir uns
darauf einstellen dass Fluchtbewegungen
langfristig zunehmen und entsprechende
Versorgungskapazitäten als Beitrag zur
Krisen Resilienz begreifen
ja in meinem es ist klar dass der
Migrationsdruck weiter der wird bleiben
für die nächste und Zukunft das war auch
schon 2015 klar und deswegen gab es ja
die Versuche das besser steuern zu
können und ich glaube das ist die
zentrale Frage des eines Geld das eine
sind die Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten aber
die Leute fragen sich können wird das
gesteuert kann das gesteuert werden und
das ist der eigentliche Punkt ich glaube
der Vertrauenskrise entsteht
zu den Regierenden wenn die Leute das
Gefühl haben das ist nicht mehr
steuerbar und und da kann man mit viel
Geld was machen mit Unterkünften aber
die Frage ist eigentlich eine andere
sozusagen wie kann man so an diesem
Migrationsdruck so kanalisieren dass er
gut hier integrierbar ist und verdaubar
ist aber darf ich da einmal also es ist
ja noch keine Vertrauenskrise da würde
ich sagen natürlich in einem sehr
kleinen Teil der Bevölkerung der aber
glaube ich grundsätzlichen Problem mit
Migration hat und grundsätzlich muss man
doch sagen es wurde ja gesteuert also
wir haben doch 20 15 gesehen selbst die
flüchtlingskanzlerin Angela Merkel nach
alle möglichen Regelungen verschärft hat
dass sie einen Deal gemacht hat mit der
Türkei dass die Zahlen rapide abgenommen
haben und über die letzten Jahre so
blieben das ist jetzt erst langsam
ansteigt und man muss ja eben sehen dass
das eben so ist weil wie Sie richtig
sagen diese ganzen Krisen in der Welt
sind und hinter vielen wo die Menschen
gerade zu uns kommen eben Wladimir Putin
steckt und der das natürlich macht um
uns eine Vertrauenskrise
anzutragen ja also man muss ja eben
überlegen wer versucht da also ich bin
gerade überhaupt nicht
sagen
es war auch 2015 war eine Phase
sozusagen weil die Grenzen offen waren
da hatten die Leute schon das Gefühl
dass hier was nicht richtig ist danach
kann man sozusagen zusammen gestoppelte
Steuerungsversuche die bis heute auch
zusammen nicht doppelt sind es ist
richtig bisher gibt sie Vertrauenskrise
nicht aber ich glaube die Frage muss man
sich stellen und dann muss das
Debattieren man muss fragen wie kann man
das Migrationsdruck der da ist der
größer werden wird eines Ukraine sein
dass jede Nachbarländer welche
Instrumente haben wir und haben wir
überhaupt die rechtlichen
Voraussetzungen dazu steuern das ist
dann wir haben doch Frau Müller hat eben
darauf verwiesen es war sicher
2015/2016 eine Ausnahmesituation aber
seitdem ist sehr stark begrenzt worden
die Zuwanderung seitdem ist mit sehr
vielen Mitteln mit einem strengen
Grenzregime mit Zäunen mit Flüchtlingen
auf dem Mittelmeer die nicht gerettet
werden mit pushbacks also den illegalen
Zurückweisungen an den Grenzen also ist
doch sehr viel unabhängig davon wie man
das bewertet aber sehr viel getan worden
um das was sie Steuerung nennen
hinzubekommen ich muss sie korrigieren
Flüchtlinge werden gerettete Mittelmeer
nicht alles über 1000 dieses Jahr schon
gestorben
sind nach Libyen zurückgebracht aber es
geht ja um die es geht nur um die Frage
nein nein mir geht's nur um die Frage
Steuerung ja oder nein und egal wie man
es nennt also auf jeden Fall wird es
nicht ein muss man das nicht einfach
geschehen
wir haben eingangs darüber geredet
nämlich ist Serbien hereinsetzer
Reserven hat de facto sozusagen ist im
Moment so was ich schwitze des Zoomen
schleuser-stadt ja natürlich Western
Maßnahmen geben die man ergreifen muss
im bezirkus Serben in Österreich ist die
die
asylanträgezahlung 195 Prozent gestiegen
die Hälfte von 195% kann man das Indien
das ist jetzt nicht ein Land wo ich sage
das ist die größte Demokratie der Welt
also das stimmt also das sind Fragen die
Leute stellen es wird natürlich
gesteuert aber ich denke das ist alles
Stückwerk und wir aber ich habe nicht
den großen Plan sozusagen um Zuwanderung
zu gestalten ist ihre These Herr wir
waren da ich finde wir machen gerade so
ein bisschen Fehler da auch gerade in
der Diskussion da ist wir müssen glaube
ich wirklich unterscheiden zwischen den
Leuten gerade die aus der Ukraine kommen
und Leuten die über die sag mal
EU-Außengrenze über die üblichen Routen
kommen weil ich glaube das ist wirklich
ein Unterschied wir haben einen Krieg
der geführt wird von Putin gegen alleine
und ich glaube es ist eingepreist eine
Migration ein migrationsstrom nach
Europa Strom falsches Wort
Entschuldigung trotzdem eine
migrationsbewegung es ist aber wirklich
wichtig dass wir uns darüber Gedanken
machen weil er hat das selbe im letzten
Jahr gemacht indem er über Belarus
Flüchtlinge nach Europa hat kommen
lassen und wenn wir den wenn wir den
Krieg verstehen wollen dann ist das ein
Krieg den japutin führt gegen das
westliche System gegen die Demokratien
und er weiß dass wir uns hiermit auch
gerne Unruhe versetzen lassen und die
Frage ist wenn wir jetzt keine Panzer
schicken aber wie viel Geld stecken wir
rein dass wir in diesem Winter halt auch
soziale Unruhen bei uns und soziale
Spannung Verhalten und dann finde ich
wenn wir jetzt 200 Milliarden Euro für
ein doppelbums geben und zwei Milliarden
im Frühjahr irgendwie für die für die
Unterstützung der Kommunen da glaube ich
ist ordentlich Luft nach oben damit wir
hier zusammenhalten und eben nicht
irgendwie Putin diesen Gefallen tun und
deswegen glaube ich müssen wir wirklich
aufpassen bei diesen zwei Bewegung genau
das heißt darauf gucken dass keine
unruhe entsteht wegen der zahlen oder
der Zahlen der geflüchteten die jetzt
diese gesagt haben die Zahlen über die
Balkanroute ist sehr ähnlich wie 218 und
da sagte Horst Seehofer wir haben alles
wieder im Griff es ist alles unter
Kontrolle und das sagte Horst Seehofer
zu diesen Zahlen ja bereits ich würde
gerne eine Sache aufgreifen die sie
vorhin gesagt haben nämlich dieses Zitat
von Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz wir
kümmern uns sozusagen um die um andere
Zuwanderungswege sage ich mal wenn wir
die illegale Migration im Griff haben
aber ist das nicht etwas was man sehr
viel als Verantwortlicher Politiker als
Bundeskanzler zumal sehr viel
strategischer angehen müsste und sagen
müsste wir machen beides wir kümmern uns
um die Frage wie kommen geflüchtete
hierher unter welchen Bedingungen wir
gehen wir mit um und gleichzeitig liebe
Leute sage ich euch aber wir brauchen
mehr Granden wir sind ein alterndes Land
wir sehen es an allen Ecken und Enden
man muss ja nur mal irgendwie in sein
Lieblingsrestaurant gehen und sehen da
funktioniert ganz vieles nicht also
ist das nicht sozusagen ein viel zu
zaghafter Umgang mit diesen beiden Polen
der Diskussion ich glaube einfach dass
der Bundeskanzler die aufkommenden
Diskussionen und Debatten sie haben in
ihrer eingangs Moderation gesagt das war
hässlich 2015
dass er die in der Nase hat dass das
einfach was kommt was was
außerordentlich unangenehm werden kann
der Unterschied und da möchte ich noch
mal anknüpfen und das was er Bewahrer
gesagt hat es gibt wirklich einen
gravierenden Unterschied
die Menschen die aus der Ukraine kommen
werden von uns nicht wie Flüchtlinge
behandelt weil sie sich auch selber
nicht als Flüchtlinge sehen sie
unterliegen auch nicht dem Asylbewerber
leistungszusetzen sondern sie
unterliegen der Grundsicherung das heißt
sie kriegen mehr Geld sie sind besser
gestellt bei der Versorgung im
Krankenhaus und so weiter das war
gewollt und zwar nicht von Deutschland
gewollt sondern von der Europäischen
Union es gibt die sogenannte so heißt
das Ding
massenzustrom Richtlinie nach der
man die ukrainischen Menschen die
meisten Frauen ein Drittel Kinder so
behandelt wie man sie behandelt das war
gewollt und dagegen gibt es jetzt und
das ist sozusagen der Auslöser dieses
Unwohlseins und dieser Diskussion um
Gipfel und so weiter gibt es ein
Ansteigen aus den Ländern aus denen die
Flugbewegungen immer schon hoch waren
und vielleicht wegen Corona eine Zeit
lang runtergesenkt worden waren und da
gibt es jetzt unterschiedliche Punkte
Damen und Herren ladona gesagt die
Serben die zum schleuserstaat geworden
sind weil sie Visa erteilen so dass alle
hineinkommen können Serben sind in
Europa der größte Verbündete von von
Putin und deswegen findet das statt
erdogan hat im Wahlkampf versprochen in
einem Jahr wird dort gewählt er schickt
Flüchtlinge wieder zurück nach Syrien
also machen die sich auf die Socken um
aus der Türkei wegzukommen und versuchen
Wege zu suchen nach Europa zu kommen das
ist im Moment die
der Punkt und der soziale Frieden der
wird davon abhängen ob man sozusagen
diese Unterschiede erkennt zwischen den
zwischen den Gruppen zwischen den
ukrainen vor allen Dingen Rinnen und
ihren Kindern und zwischen der
Einwanderung aus anderen Staaten
außerhalb der Europäischen Union ist ein
drastischer Unterschied die hohen Zahlen
die kommen daher zustande
weil die Unterbringung von Ukrainern die
ganz die im überwiegenden Sinne privat
stattgefunden hat jetzt zunehmend nicht
mehr privat stattfindet sondern die auch
in die Aufnahmeeinrichtungen gehen und
deswegen laufen die voll das ist das
Problem was wir im Moment haben
die Unterschiede müssten stärker
kommuniziert werden zwischen der einen
Gruppe von Flüchtlingen zum anderen wir
haben einen User auf Twitter der fragt
wie die Runde hier zu der
Ungleichbehandlung steht also dass die
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine besser
gestellt sind was sagen sie dazu denn es
gibt ja dazu auch schon die eine oder
andere Diskussion im politischen Raum
und die eine oder andere Frage ist es
nicht ungerecht oder sollten wir es weil
es möglicherweise ein Anreiz ist das
Zurückfahren
es gibt
Diskussionen auf der linken Seite das
etwa die Jusos das ist die größte Gruppe
der innerhalb der SPD-Fraktion gesagt
hat wir wollen das asy
oberleistungsgesetz grundsätzlich
streichen und alle sollen so behandelt
werden so privilegiert so würde ich es
ausdrucken wie diejenigen die aus der
Ukraine kommen wenn ich einen linker
werde würde ich genauso argumentieren
wir haben diese Ungleichbehandlung
lassen wir Weg wie ich darüber denke
entscheidend ist dass die meisten
Ukrainer sich selber nicht als
Flüchtlinge sehen sondern sagen wir
kommen temporär wir kommen eine Zeit
lang wir wollen zurück in unser Land und
das macht den Unterschied aus zu
Flüchtlingen aus anderen Teilen dieser
Welt Frau Müller machten sie oder haben
Sie denn Eindruck dass diese
Unterscheidung eine wesentliche Frage
ist in der Diskussion und dass das etwas
ist was entweder wenn man es gut führt
für Befriedung sorgen könnte oder
soziale also Unruhe vermeiden könnte
oder umgekehrt zu Unruhe und zu noch
mehr Streit und zwar hässlichen Streit
führen könnte also mein Eindruck ist
dass das bislang nur diese
Privilegierung die Sie ansprechen wie
Sie es nennen bislang eigentlich nur von
Pro russ
Freunden Fans wie auch immer man sie
digital mag benutzt wird um eben zu
sagen seht ihr jetzt behandelt ihr die
auch noch besser als die anderen
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen steht im
Grundgesetz Menschenwürde gilt für alle
und damit ist es eben schwierig da so
ein System auszumachen ich würde aber
auch sagen dadurch dass man eben damit
gerechnet hat dass sie für eine kurze
Weile bis dieser Krieg wie auch immer
beendet ist erstmal nur Schutz suchen
dass man dann eben das Aufenthaltsrecht
für alle macht damit die Behörden eben
nicht überfordert sind dass man das
schon auf eine Art und Weise
rechtfertigen kann ich finde aber auch
es schwierig so zu tun als an die Zahlen
vor allen Dingen wegen Corona
runtergegangen also natürlich sind sie
da noch mal ein bisschen mehr gesunken
aber wenn man sich die Tabellen anguckt
was 2015/2016 20 17 18 19 dann kam
Corona also natürlich haben all die
Dinge die wir gemacht haben und die ich
auch einigen Teilen kritisieren würde
dazu geführt dass die Migrationsdruck
auch nicht geeignetes Wort aber okay
nachgelassen hat sie haben eben von
einfaltstor gesprochen das klingt
irgendwie als würden die Hunden kommen
und uns überfallen ist finde ich super
schwierig
wir haben nicht von Hunden gesprochen
und darum ging es nun um nichts anderes
ging nicht Julian runden versuchen sie
das nicht ich sage
wieder oder also ich finde das Wort
Einfallstor klingt als würde ein Tor
fallen als Mann
ich wollte sie nicht beleidigen ich
wollte ihnen sagen einfach klingeln
sozusagen vermitteln wie es bei einem
Teil der Menschen die das Hören ankommen
und ich bin ja selber von Fakten und ich
weiß auch was Sprache kann lassen sie
uns vielleicht genau bei der Diskussion
zu Ende machen genau und ich finde das
ist gerade sehr sehr darauf ankommt wie
wir eben darüber reden und dass wir
nicht dieselben Fehler gerade im Diskurs
wie 2015 machen dass wir eben nicht so
tun als kämen Ströme haben wir eben auch
schon gesagt als Camper so eine
Naturgewalt auf uns zu als würden Tore
fallen und so weiter ich würde gerne
noch mal das passt zu einem Punkt den
wir vorhin nur gestreift haben das war
der soziale Frieden um den geht es ja
letztlich immer das ist immer auch der
Hintergrund dieser ganzen Diskussion und
wir wissen wie sensibel ist sie haben
vorhin sinngemäß gesagt Frau Müller der
sozial dass sie den sozialen Frieden
nicht in Gefahr sehen das aufs Ganze
betrachtet glaube ich gibt es auch keine
der einzige Zahl die dem sozusagen
entgegen stehen würde aber wenn wir
jetzt in Teile Ostdeutschlands gucken da
sieht es natürlich anders aus wenn wir
uns da die Sympathiewerte zum Beispiel
für die AFD anschauen oder das Hadern
mit dem Staat den Institutionen den
Politikern absolut also ich sehe ihn
insofern gefährdet wenn man jetzt
einfach so weitermacht und man das Thema
nicht in einer Art und Weise adressiert
dass man das Gefühl hat das wird was
getan also mein Plädoyer wäre
tatsächlich zu gucken wo fehlt wo viel
Ressourcen und zwar egal welche Art also
wo braucht es Personal kann man sich
weiterhin darauf verlassen dass Menschen
die sehr viel ehrenamtlich das muss man
sagen 2015 hat auch geklappt weil so
viel so viele ehrenamtleren Ehrenamtler
dabei waren machen die das jetzt
trotzdem wenn sie eben vor einem harten
Winter stehen was was passiert hier
sozusagen wer kann diesen Druck
sozusagen herunternehmen für sich
persönlich und eben auch den Kostendruck
und dann muss man eben sagen Sie haben
ja recht die FDP ist da kritischer oder
kritischste Teil sozusagen in der
Regierung was die aktuelle Situation
angeht da muss man eben sagen man muss
Geld in die Hand nehmen es wird nicht
anders funktionieren wenn man sagt man
möchte die Solidarität mit der Ukraine
man möchte eben die Leute erst mal
menschenwürdig grundsätzlich
unterbringen muss man Geld in die Hand
nehmen und da muss man eben auch über
die Schuldenbremse reden man muss Geld
die Hand nehmen aber man muss
wahrscheinlich auch politisch
kommunikativ noch eine ganze Menge
machen was bisher nicht stattfindet oder
ja und ich glaube vor allem müssen ja
schon gucken ich glaube wir haben schon
eine heikle Lage weil das war jetzt
glaube ich diese Woche der der
Deutschlandtrend der schon festgestellt
hat dass die Demokratie Unzufriedenheit
also die Zufriedenheit liegt jetzt etwa
bei Hälfte Hälfte und die
Unzufriedenheit ist 12 Prozentpunkte
oder so gestiegen und das hat natürlich
irgendwas mit dieser Lage zu tun und ich
glaube es ist schon wichtig jetzt genau
drauf zu gucken ordentlich ordentlich
drüber zu sprechen aber auch sorgen die
draußen sind irgendwie ernst zu nehmen
und dann vernünftig drüber zu sprechen
und deswegen finde ich halt auch wenn
wir jetzt über Grundsicherung ist dass
das Richtige für die Ukraine also das
hat ja zwei Aspekte es ging ja
eigentlich gar nicht anders das erste
wäre gewesen dass das BAMF uns wieder
abge schaffen wäre wie 2015
das prüft die Asylanträge und hier hat
man festgestellt die kommen aus einem
Krieg die hätten alle einen positiven
Bescheid gehabt also hat man gesagt wir
prüfen die jetzt nicht und lassen sie in
paar Monaten drin sondern sie werden
gleich anerkannt und für anerkannter
Asylbewerber kommen wir zu
Grundsicherung das ist halt der normale
Ablauf der einfach passiert ist und das
sozusagen jetzt zu hinterfragen finde
ich es halt wirklich irgendwie an einem
kleinen Rädchen dass ich rausnehmen und
das halt in ein falsches Licht stand
aber hinterfragt wird es unter anderem
auch vom CDU-Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz
der vor einigen Wochen vom
sozialtourismus der Ukrainer gesprochen
hat sich dann so zu einem Viertel
entschuldigt hat um dann vor einigen
Tagen noch mal zu signalisieren dass
diese Sozialleistung genau dass diese
Sozialleistungen doch ein zumindest zu
hinterfragen da Anreiz sein es ist nicht
genau das was sozusagen dafür sorgt dass
Unruhe aufkommt zumal dann wenn man es
wie er zunächst mal gar nicht belegen
kann es gibt einfach wenn ich jetzt
nicht über eine habe keine Belege dafür
dann ist die Einzelfälle aber wir reden
ja auch hier rüber kontrovers so muss
man darüber reden weil es es ist wichtig
aber das Wort sozialtourismus
zu nehmen wenn es einzelne Fälle gibt
und es gibt immer irgendwo Missbrauch
und der spricht von einer größeren Zahl
hat kein Beleg dafür also das erwarte
ich halt von von der größten
Oppositionspartei erwarte ich da ein
anderes Vorgehen das von der AFD sind
wir es vielleicht gewohnt immer wieder
aber bei der Union muss wirklich was
anderes dahinter stecken glaube ich wenn
wenn man da wirklich in diesem Fall
Migration eine ordentliche
Oppositionspolitik ja aufs Feld legen
will das war einfach wirklich unseriös
von Herrn März weil es sozusagen eine
Desinformationskampagne war die bei
Querdenken über russische Account
sozusagen
dass das die Sozialleistungen die
Grundsicherung die Menschen animieren
hierher zu kommen das ist im Grunde
genommen der Kern der Aussage gibt es
wirklich seriöse Studien die das
widersprechen sie hatten gerade den
dritten Weg im Hintergrund gezeigt das
ist ja nun wirklich eine
Neonazi-Partei da muss man sagen die
nutzen das Thema natürlich einfach für
ihre Zwecke also die haben auch was
Migration aber sie wollen einfach
leichter natürlich der beiden sein
sondern es geht einfach darum dieses
Argument unter die Lupe zu nehmen zu
beleuchten und zu gucken wie tragfähig
ist es heller Donner ich würde gerne
jetzt noch mal explizit zur europäischen
Ebene kommen all das worüber wir heute
reden darüber reden wir wir hier am
Tisch aber ganz viele andere Menschen
schon seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten und
man hat den Eindruck dass diese ganzen
schönen Vorsätze wir müssen die ganze
Zuwanderung und die Zuwanderungspolitik
in einen Plan gießen wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen den Flüchtlingen
und den Arbeitsmigranten wir müssen
gucken wie man mit beiden aussieht das
ist immer wieder gesagt und gesagt wird
dass es aber nicht passiert auch in
Brüssel nicht warum ist das so
ja vielleicht noch eine Satz die die zu
den Ukraine die massenzustrom Richtlinie
also die Ukraine die EU hat kein Problem
das Wort Strom zu verwenden nur das ist
kein Problem
wenn man sozusagen Worte nicht mehr
aussprechen darf
bei Natur vergleichen hat immer dieses
Gefühl da kommt ein Strom kann man ihn
aufhalten ja nein und das sind
Individuen die kommentieren
ich glaube es geht nicht darum dass man
etwas nicht darf aber wenn man etwas so
formuliert muss man damit leben können
das andere ist anders sehen und auch
wieder verteilen
es ist wenn sie zurückblicken in die
Geschichte sozusagen das
Umgangs der EU mit Migration und Flucht
und Asyl dann sehen Sie die Tendenz die
ausweit in der Asylrechts und den Abbau
des Grenzschutzes und das ist das
zentrale Problem sie haben sozusagen die
heute hat
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge politische
Flüchtlinge fast jeder hat ein
asylanspruch in der Europäischen Union
und die die Grenzen sind jetzt nicht so
durchlässige 215 aber da Grenzschutz ist
außengrenzschutz ist extrem
vernachlässigt worden dass der eine
Punkt der zweite Punkt ist der Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention die wichtig ist
die 1951 beschlossen wurde ist überhöht
worden ist eingebaut worden die
rechtliche Architektur der Europäischen
Union ist quasi sozusagen
politisches Dokument und ist über die
Jahre sozusagen ausgebaut worden mit
mehr und mehr Rechten für Leute die
kommen möchten und das ist inzwischen so
eingebaut in die rechtliche Struktur der
EU das ist kaum mehr abzubauen ist und
deswegen die Blockade es gibt einen
anderen Punkt die Nationalstaaten haben
unterschiedliche Zugänge aber es gibt
keinen Konsens darüber wie man normativ
umgehen soll Integration Flucht und das
ist das Problem
für flüchtlingskonventionen und nur
damit nicht das Missverständnis aufkommt
natürlich hat nicht jeder hier Recht auf
Asyl aber es gibt das Recht ein
Asylantrag zu stellen und das war aber
nicht immer solchen zu lassen es hat
sich gerne
nein ich glaube die grundanalyse dass
das haben wir auch gesagt dass die
Kontrolle bei der Migration bei der
irregulären Migration das muss man ja
auch sagen nicht besteht und das keine
legale Migration wirklich da ist da
Stimme glaube ich komplett über Einsatz
wenn wir nicht sitzen wenn die Politik
tatsächlich Lösungen geschafft
es ist von vornherein klar unter
bestimmten Bedingungen können auch
Menschen kommen die nicht Asyl bekommen
sondern dir hier bestimmten Berufen
nachgehen die Staaten also das eine ist
die Europäische Union das zweite sind
die Staaten innerhalb der Europäischen
Union und die gehen höchst
unterschiedlich mit den Dingen um schon
mit den Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine
gehen sie völlig unterschiedlich um
Frankreich und Italien haben kaum welche
aufgenommen und es gibt die Diskussion
darüber wie kann das eigentlich sein
dass bestimmte Länder wie Polen
Tschechien Deutschland die meisten
aufgenommen haben aber andere Länder wie
Frankreich und Italien
so gut wie gar keine aufgenommen haben
dass das eine das zweite ist Polen hat
überhaupt kein Problem damit eine
Million
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine aufzunehmen
weigert sich aber strikt wie auch
Tschechien
Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen außerhalb der
Grenzen der der Europäischen Union und
deswegen kommt es ja eben dazu dass wir
heute wieder eine Schleierfahndung haben
an der bayerischen Grenze wo gesagt wird
aus Tschechien werden sie einfach
durchgewunken wie 2015 über andere
Länder über die Balkanroute und diese
Situation ist dann ist dann wieder
vergleichbar
dazu können wir jetzt noch ganz viel
sprechen wir sind aber bald am Ende der
Sendung angelangt ich würde ganz gerne
noch mal einen kurzen Blick werfen auf
die kommenden Monate die werden auf
jeden Fall hart wir haben die Gaspreise
wir haben die Inflation wir haben eine
Rezession die uns ins Haus steht das
beschäftigt etliche europäische Länder
die Rechtspopulisten zum Beispiel in
Schweden in Italien sind erfolgreich in
Deutschland haben wir steigende
Zustimmungswerte für die AFD wie Frau
Müller müsste diese ganze Diskussion
geführt werden damit sie nicht so
hässlich wird wie wir das von 2015/2016
kennen ich würde sagen ehrlich aber mit
anständigen Worten sozusagen also
konstruktiv wie können wir dieses
Problem lösen und ehrlicherweise haben
wir uns die letzten Jahre ja auch ein
bisschen was vorgemacht wenn man
überhaupt davon ausgegangen ist dass das
Thema Migration wegkommt ja wir haben
die Klimakrise und so weiter das wird
immer mehr Flüchtlinge geben es gibt
immer mehr autoritäre Staaten auf der
Welt und so weiter Dankeschön Herr
bewahrder ganz kurz wie verhindert man
das ist eine hässliche Debatte wird
genau konstruktiv darüber sprechen aber
man muss darüber sprechen wir können
nicht einfach sagen das Problem
existiert nicht das ist das wichtige
individuellen Asylrecht Anspruch
einschränken und in Grenzschutz
verstärken
das heißt noch mehr Geld in frontext
stecken Harald
wir haben eine historische Erfahrung die
sie zu aus 1992 400.000 Flüchtlinge
danach Änderungen des Grundgesetz
Verschärfung des Asylrechts 2015 1,2
Millionen letztendlich aus dem syrischen
Bürgerkrieg danach Verschärfung des
Asylrechts die Frage ist ob es uns ob
jetzt sich das ähnliche wiederholt wir
haben eine steigende Zahl von
Asylbewerbern wir haben eine
Ampelkoalition die gerne ein
Paradigmenwechsel haben würde beim
Asylrecht wie im Koalitionsvertrag steht
und ich glaube dass der Ampel dasselbe
passieren wird wie etwa bei der
Lieferung von Waffen in Krisengebieten
sie werden sich von einem Teil der vor
allen Dingen grünen grundierten
Forderungen und verabschieden müssen ich
muss doch nur einmal nachfragen ein
Paradigmenwechsel das müssen sie kurz
erklären ein sozusagen ein grundsätzlich
von der Abwehr von Flüchtlingen
ausgegeben ausgerichteten
Migrationspolitik hin zu einer Politik
die früher mal hieß Willkommenskultur
aber sehr es kommt auch von sehr vielen
ampelpolitikern die Aussage wir müssen
natürlich sich die irreguläre Migration
wie es heißt Frequenzen ich danke meinen
Gästen hier Herrn bewerder Frau Müller
Herr Reitz und
landurner herzlichen Dank auch für ihr
Interesse hier geht es jetzt im ersten
weiter mit dem europamagazin und auf
Phoenix und WDR 5 folgt Presseclub
nachgefragt danke schön noch mal und
einen schönen Sonntag
[Musik]
ja Dankeschön so wir sind jetzt bei
Phönix nachgefragt und bei WDR 5 und
jetzt sind sie drin Liebe Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer sich mit ihren Fragen und
Anmerkungen einzubringen und ich fange
an mit Birgit Roos aus Fallingbostel
bitte schön Frau Roos
Ihre Frage ja guten Morgen hier ist Frau
Roos aus Bad Fallingbostel also ich habe
jetzt nicht direkt eine Frage ich wollte
nur mal anbringen dass halt in vielen
Ländern ja auch Kriege geführt werden
die die halt untereinander da Menschen
führen und dass die vielleicht einfach
mal aufhören sollten sich zu bekriegen
und statt dann ihre Länder zu verlassen
dass die dann halt alle hierher kommen
und dass wir halt keine mehr aufnehmen
können weil wir haben Wohnungsmangel wir
haben Lehrermangel wir haben leere
Kassen wir haben unsere eigene Probleme
teilweise wissen die Menschen selber
hier nicht mehr wie sie über die Runden
kommen soll man weiß nicht was uns noch
passiert die Sicherheit alles leidet
darunter und ich finde es auch schade
dass zum Beispiel jetzt Herr Merz mit
seiner Aussage da gleich wieder in eine
Ecke geschoben wird generell wie
Menschen womöglich auch ich jetzt
vielleicht weil ich diese Aussage
getätigt habe immer diese Rechte Keule
geschwungen wird und die Nazi Keule
rausgeholt werden auch von Frau Müller
tut mir leid wie es wahrscheinlich auch
hierfür schön grün aber aber die Welt
ist nicht nur so kunterbunt und alles
schön man muss auch mal die Realitäten
sehen und ja auch jetzt dass das noch
wieder erleichtert werden soll dass alle
hier bleiben kann ich finde es nicht
richtig jeder sollte auch in seinem
eigenen Land mal Verantwortung
übernehmen und nicht muss man anderen
Ländern
ganz cool wenn die rechte Ecke geschoben
wird auch nicht ganz schön ich glaube in
die rechte Ecke geschoben worden ist
hier heute niemand und es ging auch
nicht um parteipolitische Färbungen sie
haben gesagt eine Frage genau trotzdem
würde ich gerne Frau Müller weil sie
angesprochen worden ist das Wort geben
na klar also
bei Ungarn würde ich ihnen deutlich
widersprechen bei allem anderen
natürlich haben wir hier eigene Probleme
und müssen die Politik soll sich auch
darum kümmern es ist aber ja nicht so
als würde das nicht passieren und dann
direkt zu behaupten wenn man das
kritisiert wie dann in Teilen eines groß
geführt wird und eben Begriffe die
früher schon von der NPD benutzt wurden
wieder in den Diskurs kommen das muss
man einfach sagen können damit sage ich
jetzt nicht Sie persönlich sind ein Nazi
oder dann habt ihr eine Nazikeule
geschwungen aber natürlich geht es darum
wie Menschen miteinander sprechen und ob
man konstruktiv Probleme löst und
tatsächlich würde ich sagen es geht es
Menschen die in einem aktiven Krieg
Leben deren Häuser und Wohnung zerbombt
werden schlechter als uns hier in 99%
der Fälle
man muss ja auch sagen Friedrich Merz
hat selbst dieses Wort zurückgezogen so
das ist ein wichtiger Punkt ansonsten
finde ich sehen wir ja es gibt Sorge und
denkst ja Dankeschön so wir kommen jetzt
zur Regine Volkmann aus Caputh bei
Potsdam
welche Schulden verfolgt man
Frau Volkmann
hallo ich grüße Sie einen schönen
Sonntag ich habe eine frage sie hören
mich ja wir hören sie gut ja ich habe
eine Frage in der gesamten Runde habe
ich vermisst und in sämtlichen runden
habe ich vermisse ich den den Fakt dass
wir hier über 300.000 ausreisepflichtige
haben die hier geduldet werden und die
aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht
abgeschoben werden auch keine Straftäter
wir hätten Platz hier noch für mehr
Leute die wirklich nötig haben wenn wir
uns von diesen Leuten schon vor Jahren
getrennt hätten und auch jetzt noch
trennen würden das meine Frage
dass ich die ja herzlichen Dank verfolgt
man sie erlauben dass ich diese Frage an
Manuel bewarda weitergebe das glaube ich
tatsächlich also wir haben ja eigentlich
keinen keine Regeln im Prinzip sondern
vollstreckungsprinzip und dazu
tatsächlich die ausreisen diese
Koalition will mehr Straftäter Gefährder
abschieben
auch so sollen Leute die
ausreisepflichtig und
sind das Land verlassen das klappt nicht
das klappt seit Jahren nicht ich glaube
Olaf Scholz hat selbst als Bürgermeister
auch gesagt Seehofer solle jetzt endlich
mit den Herkunftsländern verhandeln also
hat selbst vor Forderungen gestellt das
kommt nicht voran und jetzt muss man
halt sehen diese Koalition macht das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht was dazu führt
dass Leute die wir nicht zurückführen
werden damit da müssen wir uns auch
ehrlich machen das wird nicht klappen
dass die hier auch tatsächlich
integriert werden können und dafür
hätten wir nicht von den Straftätern nur
damit das nicht durch die 300.000
natürlich alle und davon gibt es nur ein
Bereich an Straftätern
die anderen dürfen nicht abgeschoben
werden
Gefährder sind es genau sind sehr wenig
aber das ist das ist schon was wichtig
ist dass man sagt seit Jahren zuerst
will diese Regierung auch die vorgängere
Regierung will das Recht auch
durchsetzen und das klappt nicht und da
verstehe ich jeden Frust vielleicht nur
noch mal zur verklagung weil ich ja
nicht jeder den ganzen Tag damit
beschäftigt dass man sagt ein Teil der
Menschen oder großer Teil dieser großen
Zahl kann nicht abgeschoben werden weil
zum Beispiel humanitäre Gründe dagegen
sprechen die haben zwar kein Recht auf
Asyl nach dem asylartikel des
Grundgesetzes aber sie können trotzdem
beispielsweise nicht in Krieg und
Bürgerkrieg zurückgeschickt werden genau
oder medizinische oder medizinisch
Identität verschleiert haben aber
die sollen dann geduldet zu bleiben also
es geht wirklich dann in dem Fall nur um
Leute die fünf Jahre hier sind die dann
ein Jahr ein probeaufenthaltsrecht
bekommen nachweisen müssen können sie
Deutsch verdienen Sie Geld sozusagen und
dann werden sie entfristet sozusagen
Dankeschön wir kommen zu einer nächsten
Zuschauerin und zwar Gisela Kroll aus
Hamburg
Frau Kroll ja guten Morgen grüß sie ich
muss sagen jeder Deutsche nimmt
Flüchtlinge aus Kriegsgebieten oder die
wirklich gefährdet sind auf nur wenn
sich die Bevölkerung benachteiligt fühlt
und ich habe ein super Kommentar gehört
auf Phoenix da wurde ein Manager befragt
der war in Amerika in Europa überall wo
er Angst vor hat
Opas von der Finanzkrise Rezeption und
und und Angst hat darauf hat er
geantwortet er hat Angst um seine Kinder
denn der kleine Mann auf die Straße geht
und was man jetzt gehört das sind alles
nur Lippenbekenntnisse und ich möchte
nicht wissen wie viele Leute
benachteiligt sind und die auch in die
Zukunft gucken was wird investiert für
die Zukunft die Probleme die wir heute
haben die werden noch schlimmer wenn man
für viele Sachen für die Zukunft kein
Geld in die Hand nimmt danke Ihnen also
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe war
das ein Plädoyer für eine andere
Verteilung
nicht für die Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen
sondern dafür in alle Bereiche der
Bevölkerung zu schauen und so darauf zu
achten dass niemand benachteiligt wird
die Regierung versucht es ja mit hohen
Milliardenbeträgen mit infantilisierter
Sprache wie Doppel Wumms aber
bei 100 Milliarden nimmt man nimmt man
in die Hand um genau diese Effekte
abzumildern das ist auch zu weniger
Arbeitslosigkeit kommt und dass
diejenigen die sozusagen knapp über dem
Niveau der Grundsicherung sind in
Zukunft besser dargestellt werden und
auch sicherer leben können
dankeschön ich möchte jetzt kommen zu
Hans Hausmann aus Nürtingen bitte schön
Herr Hausmann
ja
hallo Hoffmann und mir fällt auf dass
ein bestimmtes Wort was
2015 in aller Munde war jetzt schon seit
ein paar Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr
erwähnt wird und dieses Wort ist
Beseitigung der Fluchtursachen es kommen
nach wie vor viele Leute aus Afrika und
da müsste man meines Erachtens etwas tun
zur Beseitigung der Fluchtursachen danke
Dankeschön Herr Hausmann das war eine
Anmerkung ich würde sie trotzdem an
sozusagen Herren Ladurner weiterspielen
teilen Sie diese Beobachtung und woran
liegt das Wort kommt nicht mehr vor aber
ich glaube schon es fehlt dass das
Konzept ist noch da und es wird auch
viel jetzt auf europäischer Ebene getan
um fruchtursachen zu bekämpfen das ist
ja schon seit die 70er Jahren ein Thema
ich glaube Willy Brandt war der erste
ist
halt nicht immer wirksam man kann
darüber reden wie man Flugzeug Sachen
bekämpft ob es überhaupt sinnvoll ist es
gibt ja auch eine Debatte bei
Entwicklungshilfe ob das richtig ist
immer es macht das ist am weitest Feld
aber ich glaube das Wort ist sich
erwähnt worden es ist richtig aber das
heißt nicht dass da nichts geschieht das
nicht das Konzept verschwunden ist auf
der anderen Seite sehen wir den Abzug
der gerade stattgefunden hat der
Soldaten aus Afghanistan die Wiederkehr
der Taliban die Unterdrückung der
Frauenrechte und der Kinderrechte vor
Ort und natürlich steigen die
fluchtzahlen da und wir haben gerade die
Problematik mit dem
internationalen Einsatz in Mali der der
vor die Wand fährt also insofern hat der
Hörer völlig völlig recht man kümmert
sich nicht um die Bewältigung um die
Beseitigung der Fluchtursachen sondern
macht im Moment das Gegenteil Dankeschön
wir kommen zu Jürgen Beck aus Dormagen
bitteschön Herr Beck ja guten Tag
ich wohne in einem Haus mit
Seniorenwohnungen da sind Rentner und
eigentlich
sind die sonst immer also gut gesinnt
gewesen gegenüber den ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen und ich muss sagen die
Stimmung kippt jetzt so langsam aber
sicher weil man doch merkt dass da so
viel Geld dabei
benötigt wird was an anderer Stelle hier
tatsächlich fehlt und ich erinnere nur
ans Ahrtal ja was da los war und jetzt
tatsächlich die Stimmung von unten
heraus
gefährlich werden könnte und ich weiß
nicht in welchen
jawohl manchmal Journalisten und
Politiker lieben die ewig miteinander zu
tun haben und an der Stimmung des Volkes
tatsächlich das Kind jetzt ein bisschen
komisch ich bin kein Querdenker oder
AFD Mann ich habe die Grünen gewählt und
bin leider auch jetzt sehr enttäuscht
dass da unser Land an die Wand gefahren
wird aber wie gesagt die Stimmung wächst
und diese Priorisierung der ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge sieht hier keiner mehr ein
Dankeschön das war auch eher eine
Anmerkung als eine Frage ich würde
trotzdem gerne Herrn sozusagen an Herrn
bewarder abgeben und sagen ist das ein
Beobachtung die sie teilen und wie kann
man denn dagegen steuern denn man kann
ja nicht sagen die Leute sollen hierher
kommen aber wir versorgen Sie nicht also
ich finde die Beobachtung tatsächlich
genau richtig ich meine man muss aber
auch sagen es gibt gerade Entwicklung im
Iran darüber diskutieren wir jetzt heute
nicht zum Beispiel sondern wir reden ja
über das Thema dass das erste ich glaube
wir haben die Probleme ziemlich deutlich
angesprochen auch die Versäumnis der
Politik und ich glaube es ist schon klar
dass genau diese dieser Engpass jetzt da
ist und wie wir damit umgehen darüber
haben wir schon gesprochen aber ich
glaube wir haben auch alle gesagt auch
von unterschiedlichen Positionen
vielleicht her man muss noch deutlicher
darüber sprechen also und insofern würde
ich sagen ja das Problem ist da aber ich
würde nicht sagen dass wir nicht darüber
sprechen und das finde ich es anders als
2015 ich finde wir haben jetzt wieder zu
lange gewartet aber wir reden darüber
und ziemlich offen und wir leben mitten
unter ihnen und haben Bodenhaftung
zumindest kann ich das das kann man ja
meistens nur für sich selber sagen aber
als Arbeiterkind habe ich da glaube ich
ganz gute Anbindung an auch andere
Sorgen und sie gehen auch als
Journalisten ständig zu diesen
Veranstaltungen und spreche auch mit den
Menschen sofern sie denn noch mit mir
sprechen weil leider hat sich dieses
diese Erzählung der Lügenpresse so weit
fortgesetzt dass auch immer weniger
Leute mit mir reden wollen obwohl ich
mit ihnen reden möchte
ja
Dankeschön wir haben glaube ich noch
Zeit für eine Zuschauerin und zwar Anja
mokos aus Köln
schönen guten Tag zusammen Anna Lukas
aus Köln ich habe großes Verständnis für
Flüchtlinge aber ich denke auch
europäisch und ich frage mich warum
unsere westlichen europäischen Ländern
nicht bereit sind auch Flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen ich meine es kann nicht
alles aus Deutschland verteilt werden es
muss eigentlich in Europa gerecht
verteilt werden das ist meine Frage ja
herzlichen Dank ich glaube alles wird
nicht auf Deutschland verteilt aber es
gibt sicher keine gerechte Verteilung
das kann man sagen diese Frage ist wie
gemacht für Ulrich Ladurner ja es ist
aber auch eine Frage wurde Flüchtlinge
bleiben wollen das ist sie können Sie
nach Bulgarien verteilen aber wenn Sie
zurückkommen nach Deutschland also die
verteilungsfrei kann man nicht
bürokratisch entscheiden sozusagen das
ist ja auch es gibt man ein Recht auf
Freizügigkeit also es ist nicht so
einfach ich glaube auch nicht dass mit
Ausländer von Ungarn nämlich viele
andere
Mitgliedsstaaten der eu-flüchtlinge auf
das von Italien verschwinden Spanien und
Frankreich also da werde ich die
Beobachtung nicht teilen ich würde gerne
Nachfrage dazu stellen und ist
vielleicht auch im Sinne unserer
Zuschauerin könnte denn an dieser
Verteilung etwas gemacht werden oder ist
es so dass sie sagen ja wenn die
Flüchtlinge da nicht hingehen wollen
dann kann man sie auch nicht zwingen
also gibt es gar keine Konzepte gar
keine Möglichkeiten dass etwas zu
steuern Residenzpflicht aber das wollen
sie ja auch nicht und als ich glaube
dass die verteilungsidee ist die
funktioniert nicht das ist einmal 250
sehen was wir Widerstand bestimmter
Staaten gescheitert ist aber sie
scheitert auch sozusagen an dem
verständlichen Wunsch von Migranten und
Flüchtlingen in bestimmten Ländern leben
zu wollen welchen anderen das man sieht
das gerade gut an den Dublins Zahlen
Dublins also dublin ist ja das Prinzip
dort wo man registriert wird diesen
zuständig für das Asylverfahren zwei 21
waren die Zahlen in Deutschland also das
Deutschland ich glaube etwa 40.000 Leute
in andere Länder rücküberstellen wollte
weil die für die Asylverfahren zuständig
waren geklappt hat es in etwa 3000
Fällen und das in der Bevölkerung klar
wird weil es hier wieder ein ein
mangelnden Vollzug an Regeln gibt das
versteht man natürlich so das kommt
gerade wieder alles zusammen und ein
mangelnden Fuß vielleicht auch weil man
den Eindruck hat immer wenn es sozusagen
die Lage sich zuspitzt dann reden alle
drüber und wenn es sozusagen nicht so
ist dann ruht der See erstmal stellt
stimmt ja auch ja in weiten Teil ja auf
jeden Fall wird das Thema uns hier am
Tisch weiter beschäftigen ich danke
Ihnen ganz herzlich den Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauern natürlich dafür dass Sie
sich hier eingebracht haben mit ihren
Fragen mit ihren Anmerkungen wie inner
hätten wir natürlich gerne noch mehr von
ihnen hier in die Sendung reingeholt
aber vielleicht gibt es an anderer
Stelle Gelegenheit Dankeschön Frau
Müller herr bewada Ulrich Reiz und